[Musique]
les érables sont évidemment connus pour
leur sève sucrés mais saviez-vous que
les feuilles d'érable ont aussi des
vertus antibactériennes qui pourraient
aider les agriculteurs c'est en tout cas
ce qui étudie des chercheurs à
l'Université Laval à Québec et le
résultat son premier
à l'automne nos forêts se partent de
manteau multicolore
les feuilles d'érable sont au cœur de ce
spectacle époustouflant à la fin de leur
parcours elle retourne à la terre et
participent au cycle de la vie mais ses
feuilles pourraient-elles être plus que
du compost
ations
de l'Université Laval Maxime Delile Hood
et Valérie Tremblay cherche à leur
trouver d'autres vertus
[Musique]
ils aimeraient notamment savoir si ces
feuilles d'érables peuvent aider les
agriculteurs à mieux protéger leur
récolte l'idée
des producteurs puisque les maladies
bactériennes sont des maladies qui sont
difficiles à contrôler il y a très peu
de moyens de lutte culturelles qui sont
très efficaces le stagiaire poste
doctoral s'est intéressé à certaines
propriétés de notre emblème national on
a découvert un extrait à base de finir
qu'une forte activité antibactérienne
présentement ici dans les airs au même
des essais notamment dans la culture de
la tomate où on tente de limiter le
développement du champ de bactérien avec
cet extrait de feuille d'érable à sucre
c'est un laboratoire que Maxime a pu
cerner le composé antibactérien miracle
la géranine ce composé phénolique de la
classe des élagitanins est aussi reconnu
pour ses propriétés
anticancéreuses
antioxydants et anti-inflammatoires
identifiez pour la première fois chez le
géranium de tomber la géranine se
retrouve aussi chez d'autres espèces
comme l'érable de Nico où le litchi
chevelu la surprise c'était de découvrir
sa présence dans un arbre de chez nous
la première fois dans les feuilles
d'érable à sucre puis on a démontré qu'à
certaines concentrations ça pouvait
altérer l'ultra structure bactérienne
c'est à dire la structure externe de la
bactérie
le procédé de fabrication est assez
simple après avoir broyé les feuilles
d'érable les scientifiques les mélanges
avec de l'éthanol pour en extraire le
composé actif
quand le solvant était vaporé il reste
une poudre fine
qui est vraiment notre concentré notre
extrait concentré d'érable qui est des
propriétés antibactériennes qu'on veut
simplement solubiliser cette poudre là
avec de l'eau puis on vient vaporiser ce
produit ensuite sur les plans pour
contrôler la maladie
donc si on a les symptômes typiques de
la maladie donc sur les fruits on peut
voir les ce qu'on appelle les champs on
a aussi des chancres sur la tige donc on
peut remarquer des gars ici sur la tige
sont causés par la bactérie
qui est encourageant c'est qu'on n'a pas
de symptômes de phytotoxicité sur les
plans donc ça on peut dire que c'est un
produit qui n'est pas au plan lorsqu'on
l'applique au début on n'était pas
certain que plus ça va qu'on a des
résultats qu'on aime donc on se dit que
ah oui peut-être ce produit
en plus de la tomate la laitue et la
fraise sont aussi dans la mire des
chercheurs
la Grenoble François Demers collabore
aux travaux de recherche
il conseille une trentaine de
producteurs de petits fruits et de
légumes dans les régions de Québec et
chaudière à palaches
a eu lieu au niveau des fleurs puis on
peut voir les symptômes qui ont apparu
environ une dizaine de jours après
l'infection c'est les symptômes qu'on
voit ici sur internet pour nous autres
c'est un plus c'est certain parce que ça
pourrait avoir un impact sur plusieurs
maladies bactériennes puis dans cette
offre à outils là on est quand même très
limité
pour les agriculteurs les recherches sur
les maladies bactériennes sont de plus
en plus importantes en ces temps de
changement climatique l'enjeu c'est que
le producteur peut avoir des pertes
importantes ça peut être au niveau des
récoltes au niveau de la croissance nous
autres la manière qu'on visualise ça au
champ ça peut être soit des pourritures
soit des tâches des nécrose
[Musique]
un symptôme qu'on constate au champ pour
cette variété-là la possibilité de se
servir des feuilles d'érable permettrait
de réduire l'utilisation d'autres
produits plus nocifs pour
l'environnement ça m’apparaît sain il y
a quand même des confirmations à faire à
ce niveau-là puis ça nous offrirait des
alternatives
à certains produits comme le cuivre par
exemple qui est très sollicité au milieu
agricole
fédérables ça devient une alternative
durable ou pesticides chimiques qu'on
utilise présentement qu'on pourrait
utiliser justement pour régler des
problèmes communs qui rendent nos fruits
et légumes non commercialisables en ce
moment la prochaine étape de validation
va se dérouler sur le terrain on a
beaucoup de variables qu'on peut
contrôler donc les précipitations comme
la pluie on a du vent du soleil qui peut
être beaucoup de facteurs et si notre
produit permet de contrer la maladie
malgré tous ces facteurs-là qui on ne
peut pas contrôler ça veut dire qu'on a
un produit qui qui vient marcher puis
qui peut vraiment aider les producteurs
en plus de l'érable à sucre les
recherches se font aussi sur l'érable
argenté et bientôt l'érable rouge si les
tests sont concluants
l'approvisionnement ne sera pas un
problème ce ne sont pas les érables qui
manquent au Canada j'espère bien qu'un
jour ils vont reproduire qui va être
disponible qui va commercialisé à base
de feuilles d'érable puisqu'il va venir
en aide aux producteurs parce que moi en
tant que agronome même si on première
c'est de trouver des réponses aux
problématiques et encore plus des
réponses aux problématiques des
producteurs locales
une vie alternative comme naturelle
meilleur pour l'environnement qui
apporte des changements concrets donc on
peut voir les changements que ça apporte
puis je trouve que c'est quelque chose
qu'on peut être fier
[Musique]